hey you guys this is Brian Head Welch
from the band Korn and I want to give a
huge 25th anniversary congratulations to
Dave Ramsey and his whole organization
and team what a huge accomplishment you
guys Wow congratulations Dave you know
what many of my family members in
California just started taking the
courses in the last year so you know
what I believe that your impact is gonna
keep growing and growing and growing so
here's to the next 25 years you guys
keep working hard keep going see ya Wow
thanks Brian my cool factor just went
way up if you just have Brian Head Welch
ever say your name out loud that's like
makes you pretty cool right there pretty
fun stuff very cool so we continue our
25th anniversary segments here in the
month of September by next month you'll
be you'll be shut up as we won't do it
anymore we promise but we continue to
celebrate we've been taking the segments
every so often and reminiscing in some
way or another and you know one of the
things that is iconic about this show if
you didn't know is the debt-free scream
usually once an hour somebody has gotten
in touch with Kelly and gotten in line
it's about a six-week backup most of the
time to you know call in or come into
the lobby and tell their story I
interview you learn a little bit about
your story and we record it on YouTube
and it's on our YouTube channel you can
watch the debt free screams you can
watch it live and you can certainly
listen to it on radio anywhere in the
United States with 590 stations so it's
just iconic it's a you know when people
think of Dave Ramsey one of the things
they think about is the debt-free scream
and it is one of those happy accidents
in a sense that happened on radio the
the first time it happened I think we I
don't know the exact date and I was
trying to calculate the other day
because we're talking about it somewhere
1718 years ago something like that a
lady called in
you know I do remember she was from
Grand Rapids Michigan and she was just
one from the time I picked up the phone
she was on fire I mean she basically
verbally machine-gunned me when I picked
up the phone she was like I sold
everything I had a garage sale man a guy
came to my house I sold my bushes out of
the front of the house Dave we're not
free
we're dead free we're dead free and she
hung up like what just happened it was
so long ago that we had a fax machine
you remember those we had a fax machine
you could fax in questions and comments
on the show and the fax machine in the
studio this de fax machine goes off and
starts going and people are riding in on
the fax that's the best call you've ever
had was awesome day those awesome now
didn't do anything I didn't even say
anything I picked up the phone and she
took off and then she hung up I didn't
it was not a conversation that was the
first debt free scream Blake and I are
laughing about it and we were laughing
about everybody's responses so visceral
it was so passionate and I was like yeah
that's how it feels you pay a price to
win that's how it feels man and this old
country guy calls up about two weeks
later I dive I dive Dave I won't do it
that free scream thing Dave I want do
that scream I'm like what are you
talking about that woman that called in
scream she's dead free I want to do that
I'm like you you want to scream you're
dead you like oh well tell me what
happened I've been working my butt
working my butt off I've been working
like three jobs it's crazy man I've done
doing all the I got this I paid off
$65,000 in debt I said well okay if you
want to scream your debt free screaming
I hung up man this is weird but you know
again the fax machine goes up that's so
cool y'all do that all the time I'm like
okay maybe we should it ones like
something we dreamed up and so this will
be
really cool idea and it'll be a great
marketing icon 25 years later and
everyone will know us for this no it
wasn't like that at all it was more like
these people wanted to celebrate their
hard work and their victory and we were
the best of the place for them to do
that absolutely incredible and so we
said hey if you want to call in and tell
your story into a debt-free screen
that's fine well then we go on Fox
Business Network if you didn't know we
had we were when Fox Business Network
very first open we were one of the shows
that opened the network with the
whatever you call that the debut of the
network had a show in the evenings there
an hour show every night in primetime
it was very popular for about six months
and then it went down down down down
down and was horrible as they shifted
their audience towards older people and
I we don't have a lot of older people in
our audience most of our people are
younger and anyway we were on there for
two years and we were doing debt free
screams for two years people would call
it well this guy mails he comes to our
office from Indianapolis we're in
Nashville we had a mailbox outside he
comes on Saturday we're closed on
Saturday but he knew that he came anyway
he took a picture of himself mailing his
last payment into that mailbox outside
of our office mailed us the picture to
use on Fox Business when he did his
death free scream I might do why did you
drive to Nashville to mail your payment
because Dave that's where it all
happened that's financial piece of lies
oh that's the your place this is the
place man this is the deal and man I
just I had to be there in your place and
well then if you don't know the show is
on the glass and it's across a lobby I'm
looking out right now at folks sitting
out here and we have a place called
Martha's place that's that Miss Dorothy
runs over there and it's got free coffee
and cookies and you know homemade
everything and it's all free and got to
work you know a bookstore over there
people come in and they would want to
use they come in to wonder they're
debt-free scream and use the phone the
telephone over there by the cash
register because they could grab the
cord and rip across
look through the doorway at me in the
glass the other side of the lobby so we
could talk across the lobby in a sense
and then they kept doing that until they
kept pulling the phone they pulled her
out of the wall broke my phone and we
kept doing these debt-free screams that
was scratchy crazy so then we finally
just put sports headsets in here you
know like I wear everyday and makes it
easy to control the microphone and you
know the people get the right you know
the right volume and so forth there so
we put all of that in place and then you
know people stand over there and look
across the lobby now and I can just have
an actual conversation and they're not
tearing up stuff and and then they do
their that free scream so a lot of
people want to travel here to do their
debt free scream here so they come from
Seattle they come from Indianapolis they
come from Dallas they come from Phoenix
they come from Miami and New York come
from everywhere it's unbelievable man
and they it's amazing what the and but
it's all about they just want to have
that moment of celebration that you know
that just after doing all the hard work
of course some of them are really funny
and fun and some of them are really sad
and the number of times someone starts a
debt free journey and then loses a
spouse during that time you know 32
years old he dies of cancer but he said
you know finish this finish this and she
finishes it and she's standing here
you know 34 years old with a couple of
little kids as a widow and doing her
debt-free scream and we're all crying
like you know thirteen-year-old girls is
unbelievable you know I mean it just
makes us all ball or you know people
that have fought through cancer while
they were getting out of that all that
kind of stuff the whole thing all the
way around I mean it's it's pretty
amazing and now we got a real strict
screening process to get to do your
debt-free scream Kellie is in charge of
all things strict here and that's just
one of them and so like if you're still
using your credit card we're not gonna
let you do your debt-free scream if you
turn on went back in debt you're not
gonna do a debt-free screen and if you
haven't figured out how to do the stuff
we're teaching and you're just half
about doing this we don't want to
glorify that that's not what we're
trying to do we're trying to get people
to do this stuff that helps them when
they causes them to succeed and so you
know you got you gotta have you know you
can't I'm paid off two thousand dollars
it took me eight years that nobody wants
to listen a crap we're not putting that
on the air but you know I mean you know
so Kelly she talks you through this and
so don't don't just book a trip and say
show up here and think you're gonna do
your debt-free scream you got to talk to
Kelly you got to go through the
screening process and you know we got a
check make sure you're real and all that
it and then we'll book you in here and
get you on the schedule so don't just
show up it's backed up like six weeks
it's a big deal now the debt free
screams part of our 25th anniversary
celebration hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]